this attack was so sudden and so deadly
many of the civilian victims died where
they were
an elderly man's hand is Frozen on his
steering wheel
his body slumped across the passenger
seat
others still packed in their cars their
bodies covered with sheets by those who
found them
young women slaughtered before they'd
even had time to run to safety
this was an aid Convoy Medics amongst
them who were on their way to help those
trapped or trying to flee an area just a
few kilometers away and already seized
by Russian troops
those who somehow survived stood in
shock as the bodies of those who didn't
were retrieved
body bag after body bag was loaded onto
a succession of ambulances we counted 15
bodies just whilst we were here
thank you
several of these vehicles still have the
bodies of the victims inside them there
are at least four just in that one
vehicle alone another two here and this
was clearly a line of Civilian cars
so mourning the dead has to give way to
the criminal investigation to try to get
Justice for these people and their
families
we spot Olga who's been trying to find
her parents who are both doctors and
were in the Convoy all she knows is her
father is here somewhere what's happened
to them just called me because that
probably I don't know what there was she
was injured and he tried to save her
life around an hour I don't know
actually what happened exactly when she
finds him he's distraught
her mother hasn't made it
the two are reduced to saying their
final goodbyes amidst the investigation
in the car park
the attacks have been condemned by The
ukrainians Who say Russia is
deliberately targeting civilians I see
you we see Vinita creaming soup and Etc
and that's really horrible war crimes
and we should we should punish Putin for
this good thing thank you sir this this
is seen in Ukraine as retaliatory action
taken by an enemy on the back foot in
the battlefield and threatening worse to
come Alex Crawford Sky News in
zapparisha Ukraine
[Applause]